let's think back to yesterday for the
benefit of those who weren't there and
for the benefit of us who were there and
countrymen pub okay we had a look at a
special kind of nut box
started with an S to sit order of up so
that's very good thank you
SADS shirt are special and we compared
them with two other kinds of numbers we
compared them with numbers like this
yeah oh yeah we get we get two I haven't
quite got there yet so this one before
that this is a terminating decimal
remember that yes good so it just stops
terminates that's not the only kind of
decimal that you are familiar with from
last yeah we had the elevator music of
the decimal world right recurring
decimals very good right which goes on
and on forever
right this is zero point three three
three three two three two three or
sometimes you might have another
repeater in there for instance what we
do have a look at was just as an example
zero point two if I have two repeated
dots what would that mean what should
not be equal to yeah yes that's right so
could somebody tell me what should
actually write yes - seven - seven -
seven and just just in case you're
curious
that's 27 789 you can verify with your
calculator so we looked at turn eight
decimals we looked at recurring s holes
and we said CERN's they're weird they're
really really weird I think the example
we looked at was like the square root of
seven okay and it was it's going to be
now by the way before you reach for your
calculators do get them out but before
you actually punch in I can know right
away even though I don't actually know
the exact value I know that this is
going to be somewhere between two and
three think for a second how do i
daughter not just because I'm a math
teacher and I've looked at this
a lot of times without reaching for a
calculator how do I know it's to point
something let's actually write down
let's get the number before we get your
answer if it's get you can't later out
now it's to point what's or to read it
after we daniel if you go there yeah
yeah breathe okay that's good thank you
that's enough okay soon like I said two
point something even did you have a
suggestion wow that was so by blur I
think I'm still recovering um I'm gonna
go on that idea of comparing with
different numbers don't you since yes
you yeah that's confusing as well isn't
it taking the square root taking the
square is my remedy
let me show you how I thought it through
let me show you how it so true remember
this sign Fiat right it means square
root it means figure what is the number
that if you square it you get seven
right and if you go back and when you've
got that in your calculator display sure
enough if you get square it'll give you
seven back
now what that means is they're not all
square roots not all of them behave in
this weirdo way right some of them are
just nice neat numbers for instance nice
little disposed for it right the square
root of four is the number you square
and will give you four so all together
now the square root of four is good
there are loads more though right so
therefore by the way the square root of
four is not a serf because it's a nice
happy normal number huh okay square of
four is nice and neat the square root of
nine is also nice and beat and it's
three now look at this look at this
seven is between four and nine it's
between four hundred okay so if this
gives me two and this gives me three
that I must be some wood between two and
three you see what I did that
okay let me give you another example you
see if you could work it out with me
don't shout it out just speak about it
because some of you will get it quicker
than others the square root of 30
oh shut up this is another messy number
it's a CERN it's gonna give me some some
garbage over here okay but if you think
about it you can work out which should
not lose it's between think think raise
even if you think you know six and five
does it check out how would we know for
sure
five right is the square root of what
number 25 birthday we actually looked at
that particular example yesterday six is
the square root of what number 36 great
and look 30 is pretty much smack bagging
between 25 and 36 so therefore I'm
expecting that it's between these guys
five point did you work it up we get the
idea thank you okay so you can use this
little mental trick right even if you
don't know what the exact number is you
know what ballpark it's in and that's an
enormous the useful skills you go
forward alright now that's what we
looked at yesterday but why are we even
looking at serbs in the first place you
can make a new heading now which is
Pythagoras's theorem because this is
actually the name of the topic what does
what do is certs have to do with this
make that heading as you'll make it I
would like to pose this question to you
why do we care about certs
why are surd's important you survived
you survived you guys are what 12 13 you
survived it's 40 you survived you know I
12 to 13 years of your life without
knowing what these things are and you
just got along fine right not only that
but these are weird numbers these
numbers they don't seem to occur in
nature do thing these others they're
okay
right there it's like oh yeah how many
how many houses are there River over
there there are five houses in a row
okay how many how many cars have passed
this street 22 cars normal numbers but
these numbers are not right you'd never
go to dinner can you say yeah I'd like
route three doughnuts please you know
and they like yeah sure that'll be I'll
be rude two dollars like that this
doesn't happen okay
these numbers these these Serbs they
don't come up in nature or do they so
under this heading let me show you how
these emerged you will need a ruler for
this if you don't have a ruler I hope
you can borrow off the person next to
you hit up if you do have a rule up
hands up straight heads up straight are
we pretty good okay hands down if you
don't have a ruler
please don't get one they're not
expensive I can't lend you one but you
really do need one that it's gonna
become a bit of paper you to constantly
borrow so for now maybe just use the one
next to you I'd like you to draw some
triangles with me I can't we're gonna
draw some right angle trip yeah great
okay so here's the first time God like
you draw okay
I'd like you to writing your triangle
like that is ever gonna think back to
the work you do with angles last year
how do we signify a right angle what do
we when we put in there no good a little
square like so so got a right angle in
there okay
now we're going to draw a variety of
triangles today and we're going to label
them and all that kind of thing now it's
okay if you draw your triangle already
but if you have it just still going I'd
like this to be a three centimeter by
three centimeter that's okay if it's not
I just want you to mark it as three set
of eyes for you
obviously mine is not three centimeters
I'm just labeling it as such now three
centimeters by three servings now this
is a nice normal numbat to decide you
want your side lengths to be okay if you
have made your size those legs okay and
then get your ruler out again and you
look at what's this third side over here
no this third side has an important name
the longest side and writing the
triangle starts with an H yes it's very
good if you are not heard that word
before do you write it down it's a long
word it's a bit tricky to spell
hypotenuse the hypotenuse of this
triangle when you measure it out well
you look at yours like how more use it
actually in centimeters has anyone
actually got a 3x3 triangle there and
can measure the hypotenuse what if it's
like 4.1 I want to put a question mark
there because if you look very closely
at your ruling yeah you might have said
you - it 4.2 question mark okay it's
kind of it's not like right on one of
the markers it's somewhere in between
for everyone this is anyone for
is that the ruling guys everybody
understands we're just introducing
where we've been looking at these
strange these strange numbers why the
change do you guys know what's the
metaphor we learned yesterday for what
serdes are yes we need certs crazy
immortal jazz musicians and you can
hassle one of these lovely children and
they said so much you want to explain
crazy or right fair enough
Thank You mr. Joseph okay okay all right
now by the way does anyone have any
other measurements open one for [ __ ]
we generally Rachel dear 4.3 okay it's
all still the same ballpark yeah they
said 4.3 is the hipster options like 10
4.1 4.2 a to Main Street for me all
right now there's a problem what's going
on what's it actually equal to okay no
we'll come to the answer in a second but
my point is it's a weird number and
we're getting different things for it
however not all triangles at a right
angle give you these weird numbers let's
draw another one this time the
dimensions might be familiar to some of
you instead of three by three I want to
make it three by four okay so three
centimeters this way shocking your right
ankle and measure out four centimeters
three four and that you're gonna have
the hypotenuse over here okay now do try
and measure as carefully as you can if
you've got a grid book that might help
you out but it's not necessary the ruler
should give you enough accuracy how
would you start drawing a new triangle
okay it's bigger this time it's gonna be
five and twelve okay again a right angle
now as you're drawing that let's look at
this three four triangles
if this time you measure this hypotenuse
over here with a reasonable degree of
certainty you should be able to find its
bang on five centimeters and if it's not
what I would put that down to is just
little inaccuracies in your ruler and
the drawing of your line but essentially
you should be on fire right you
shouldn't be very far away
that's unusual it's this nice precise
neat number all right and if you have a
look at five centimeters over here and
twelve 70s again pull out your ruler
we're starting to get to the limits of
most of your workbooks with 12 centers
should fit if you got five here and a 12
here when you measure cross again you
should be very close going on to a nice
number 14 set of me okay
not only that but everyone across the
room is getting pretty consistent
results now this is this is what maths
is about okay it's not like some people
in a arm in a room dark room so we
decided that let's think of how we can
either talk mid the minds of young
children let's write textbooks it boy
this is not bad for this is quite good
let's write books and make children
study them which is really really
complicated and random and make students
memorize rules that's not what it's
about
it's about looking at things occurring
like you know you want to build a
building where you try to figure a
distance review do things that happen in
real life and you know just patents and
then we try to understand those that's
what that is about
so by now you should have all of these
if you are very adventurous and you have
a big enough book you can draw a third
one which is I wouldn't I like to draw
it to scale but if you do eight
centimeters along here and 15
centimeters along with you some of you
will have a book that's a bit too small
for that and that's okay but again
you'll find something unusual about the
hypotenuse if you measure it and you
measure accurately it would bang on on a
certain length a whole number
fantastic you should
find bang on 17 okay if not just recheck
the way you've constructed us so now
here's what's going on you've got these
unusual triangles they not the only ones
by the way there's a whole bunch of
other ones okay but these guys are weird
they give you your whole lovers here
rather than like most triangles are like
this they give you these reader numbers
which as you might be on a tough line we
looked at yesterday they are cert and
that's why when you measure them it's
like I don't know it's kind of from it's
so weird number like this you can't
measure that with a ruler it's not
accurate enough so the question is well
what is this actual length equal to and
it was Pythagoras this ancient Greek guy
who worked out well among many other
people who worked out what is equal to